I think that mental health piece is so
important because I got a close friend
he's like 11 to 12 years old at the time
and somebody came in the house killed
his shot his mother and father killed
both of them he hid in the closet and
watched everything so I think he saw
what happened as he got older and older
years years later he became a shooter he
became a killer he just wanted to attack
people he just wanted to shoot people so
he ended up getting life in prison
he ain't gonna never come home so I'm
saying a lot of people be like I'd say
be exposed to violence so early on but
they don't get no type of treatment no
healing at nothing and so they just
think it's okay to act out you got to
see the warning signs are so important
warning signs
I know it's it's friends or family or
somebody see some type of warning signs
everybody talked to somebody when I was
out there indulging and making bad
choices in my life doing the things I
was doing I would share something with
somebody it's got to be seeing more
warning sign that's why I say we need a
system in place where we could detect
early warning signs and talk to the
right people